[Musik]
Tatort Deutschland die crime Doku von
Bild
heute versetzen wir uns in eine Lage die
sich wahrscheinlich keiner von uns so
richtig vorstellen kann ich bin Toni
Heyer und ich bin Mirko Kasimir hallo
und herzlich Willkommen Mirko kannst du
dir nach all den Monaten die wir jetzt
schon zusammen diesen Podcast ja
aufnehmen könntest du dir da vorstellen
dass ich einfach so um die Ecke gehe und
zwei Leute umbringe ach Toni ich habe
mir irgendwie schon gedacht dass du mit
irgend so eine Frage um die Ecke kommst
im Angesicht des heutigen falls aber die
Antwort ist natürlich nein aber wer weiß
was da vielleicht schon seit Jahren in
dir brodelt
lass dich überraschen nee
im Ernst im Fall Anja und Andreas dazu
gab es wirklich genau das das also einer
sich plötzlich als Mörder entpuppt
diesen Fall aus Hessen hat
bildreporterin Lena Zander verfolgt und
sie unterstützt uns heute mal wieder es
ist eigentlich ein Nachbarschaftsstreit
der eskaliert es ist eine schöne
idyllische ganz normale verspießige
Reihenhaussiedlung in Babenhausen
ungefähr 34 Kilometer von Frankfurt
entfernt und dort haben Anja und Andreas
da so Tür an Tür mit dem ehepartie und
dessen Behinderter Tochter Astrid gelebt
und es soll immer wieder gerade nachts
auch sehr laut geworden sein
astridiver geistig behindert litt unter
anderem an einer Form des Autismus und
dann soll es auch zu Türen Geknalle
gebräuter tierischen lauten gekommen
sein und dann an einem Tag im April 2019
soll Andreas da so laut Gerichtsurteil
rübergegangen sein und erst Klaus t und
dann dessen Ehefrau Petra Tee erschossen
haben dann hatte auch noch auf Astrid
geschossen aber Astrid überlebte schwer
verletzt und das Ehepaar die ist
gestorben
okay wir haben jetzt einmal die Eckdaten
gehört es geht uns heute also weniger um
die Auflösung eines Mordfalles sondern
um die Frage was macht so ein Fall mit
deinen Ängsten Angehörigen wie
verkraften ist deine liebsten wenn du
zum Verbrecher wirst oder vielleicht
auch kann man einen Mörder weiterleben
am frühen Morgen des 11 mai 2010 erlebt
Anja darsow die letzten normalen Momente
ihres Lebens wir haben ein richtiges
spießerleben sagt die wahlhessen später
zu Bild am Sonntag und das sieht so aus
Anja und Andreas kennen sich schon seit
ihrer Jugend
1995 heiraten sie und kaufen bald danach
eine Eigentumswohnung
1999 ziehen sie in einen Reihenhaus in
Babenhausen bei Frankfurt beide finden
dass sie eine gute Ehe führen die dasos
haben drei Kinder die im fraglichen
Zeitraum also im Frühjahr 2009 und 11
Jahre alt sind der jüngste Sohn wurde
gerade erst geboren Andreas arbeitet als
Einkäufer an einer Baufirma Anja macht
Minijobs im Hotel Gewerbe das Leben im
Babenhausener Doppelhaus könnte eine
Dill sein wenn da nicht die Nachbarn
werden
nebenan wohnt das Ehepaar Tee mit seiner
Erwachsenen behinderten Tochter Astrid
die damals 37 Jahre alt ist
Immobilienmakler Klaus t ist 62 seine
Frau Petra 58 das Problem die da so
finden ihre Nachbarn einfach zu laut
hauptsächlich weil die geistig
Behinderte Astrid immer wieder schrille
Laute von sich gibt aber auch andere
Dinge stören angeblich zum Beispiel das
Familie Tee mitten in der Nacht Müll
rausbringen
das Unheil dass sich da wahrscheinlich
schon seit Jahren zusammenbraut das
eskaliert am 17 April 2009 Anja fährt
mit den Kindern zu einem Fest ihrer
Familie in Mecklenburg-Vorpommern
Andreas bleibt allein zu Hause weil er
kein Urlaub bekommen hat am 18 April
einem Samstag ruft Andreas seine Frau an
und erzählt in der anderen
Doppelhaushälfte sei etwas Furchtbares
passiert
jemand habe Klaus und Petra t erschossen
auch Tochter Astrid sei getroffen worden
aber offenbar noch am leben diese
Nachrichten sind schockierend ein Mord
direkt nebenan wer tut so etwas
Schreckliches war vielleicht auch
Andreas in Gefahr ohne es zu wissen Anja
ist zwar besorgt aber sie bleibt wie
geplant insgesamt vier Tage bei ihren
Eltern im Nordosten Deutschlands
das Land ist geschockt vom Doppelmord in
der Bild steht
Familiendrama Eltern tot Tochter
überlebt nach Not-OP Frankfurt nach
einer Familientragödie im südhessischen
Babenhausen mit zwei Toten sind die
Hintergründe unklar anwohner hatten die
geistig behinderte Tochter 37 schwer
verletzt mit Schusswunden vor dem Haus
gefunden drinnen entdeckte die Polizei
die erschossenen Eltern die Tochter ist
nach einer Not-OP außer Lebensgefahr war
aber noch nicht vernehmungsfähig
wochenlang kennen die knapp 17.000
Einwohner von Babenhausen kein anderes
Thema als das Blutbad bei Familie Tee
am 11 mai 2010 hat die Polizei endlich
einen Täter ermittelt und Anja dazu
erfährt dies auf die denkbar
fürchterlichste Weise morgens klingeln
Polizisten an der Tür sie sind gekommen
und Andreas abzuholen Andreas den
mutmaßlichen Doppelmörder von
Babenhausen
[Musik]
es wurde ermittelt und Andreas da so
geriet relativ schnell als
Hauptverdächtiger dann auch ins Visier
er würde zum ersten Mal im Mai verhört
und da hat man nämlich schon eröffnet
dass als Hauptverdächtiger wegen
Doppelmordes unter Verdacht steht man
muss dazu sagen es gab natürlich auch
diese Sachen wie es war bekannt dass die
Nachbarn laut gewesen sind Andreas und
Anja da sie sollen laut Urteil auch
vorgehabt haben oder in Betracht gezogen
haben ihr Haus zu verkaufen dann wurde
sein Arbeitscomputer durchsucht und auf
diesen Arbeitscomputer hat man gefunden
dass er nach einer Bauanleitung
gegoogelt hat wie baut man einen
Schalldämpfer und dieser Schalldämpfer
ist relativ zentral weil der auf diese
Pistole gesetzt wurde der wurde mit
Bauschaum und einer PT Flasche
hergestellt und wenn man diese Anleitung
bei ihm auf dem Computer gefunden hat
hat man gesagt okay er hat sich vorher
informiert er hat das ganze auch geplant
und hat diesen Schalldämpfer hergestellt
draufgesetzt und dann ist ihr paar
erschossen fast zwei Jahre nach der Tat
beginnt der Prozess vor dem Landgericht
Darmstadt der Staatsanwalt fordert
lebenslänglich Andreas darssow
bestreitet die Tat für uns kommt nur
Freispruch in Frage sagt sein Anwalt
Christoph lang dazu schweigt laut dem
Gericht verhielt es sich so am frühen
Morgen des 17 April 2009 lauert Andreas
seinem Nachbarn Klaus t vor der
Kellertür auf schießt ihn in Hand Nase
brustarm und Hals insgesamt sechs
Schüsse da ein selbstgebauter
Schalldämpfer in der Waffe ist wird
niemand geweckt Andreas schleicht sich
ins Schlafzimmer im ersten Stock des
Wohnhauses und tötet die schlafende
Ehefrau Petra T mit zwei Schüssen
anschließend schießt er der 37-Jährigen
Tochter Astrid die im zweiten Stock
schläft ebenfalls in den Kopf er nimmt
an dass auch sie tot ist und verlässt
das Haus
der Teil mit Astrid ist das besonders
grausame an diesem Mord sie überlebt sie
blutet stark sie irrt durchs Haus und
sieht ihre Toten Eltern irgendwann geht
sie in den Vorgarten und kauert sich hin
aber erst am nächsten Tag entdeckten
Passanten sie und rufen dann Hilfe und
plötzlich ist mein Mann ein Doppelmörder
ich bin aus meiner heilen Welt gefallen
sagt Anja darf zurückblickend von einem
Moment auf den anderen ist alles anders
sie wird im Supermarkt schräg angeguckt
sie ist die Ernährerin der Familie sie
ist alleinerziehende Mutter vor allem
aber muss sie sich entscheiden wem sie
glaubt der Staatsanwaltschaft oder ihrem
Mann Andreas
für das Gericht ist die Sache überhaupt
gar nicht kompliziert im Juli 2011
verurteilt es Andreas darssow zu
lebenslanger Haft wegen besonderer
Schwere der Schuld ist eine vorzeitige
Entlassung ausgeschlossen obwohl es
keine Beweise gibt keine DNA-Spuren
keine Zeugen keine Tatwaffe die Revision
wird ein Jahr später vom zweiten
strafsinnat des Bundesgerichtshofes in
Karlsruhe verworfen die Nachprüfung des
Urteils habe keine Rechtsfehler zu
Lasten des Angeklagten ergeben heißt es
in der Mitteilung der Staatsanwaltschaft
das Urteil ist rechtskräftig und Anja
das ist Urteil ich habe einer da so
genau getroffen und ich habe sie doch
wirklich als sehr sympathische auch
reflektierte Frau kennenlernen dürfen
Anja da so hat sich irgendwann dafür
entschieden zu glauben dass ihr Mann
unschuldig ist sie hat sich alle Akten
besorgt sie hat es gelesen sie sagte
auch natürlich ich bin ich bin die
Ehefrau man muss sich das mal vorstellen
dass Baby war gerade wenige Wochen alt
das dritte Kind als der Ehemann wegen
Doppelmordes verdächtig wird und dann
stehst du da als Ehefrau bis eine ganz
normale Frau hast ein ganz normales
Leben lebst im Reihenhaus drei Kinder
hast dein Ehemann kennengelernt da warst
du 14 mit 18 wirst du ein paar mit 22
heiratest du und von heute auf morgen
ist dein Ehemann ein Doppelmörder wie
lebt man damit wie geht man mit diesem
Alltag um und wie erklärt man das auch
den Kindern und was macht das auch mit
dieser Paarbeziehung war ein Liebespaar
zu sein ist natürlich auch schwierig
wenn der Partner hinter Gittern sitzt
natürlich gab es viele Tränen bei den
Kindern berichtet Anja daraus so im
Gespräch mit der bild-reporterin aber
sie habe ihnen gesagt dass ihr ein
Fehler passiert ist dass ihrem Papa
gerade Unrecht passiere
Andreas darssow leugnet die Tat seine
Frau glaubt ebenfalls fest an seine
Unschuld sie liest alle Akten vertieft
sich in Details der angeblichen Tat ich
kann das auch ein bisschen
nachvollziehen wenn Sie zum Beispiel zu
Lena sagt wenn jemand so etwas macht
dann ist er krank im Kopf ich kenne
Andreas seit ich 14 bin ich hätte
gemerkt wenn Sie etwas in seinem Kopf
vorgeht Zitat Ende also die kennt ihn
ewig sie liebt ihn es kann nicht sein
dass er auf drei Nachbarn geschossen hat
auch für ihre älteren Kinder ist die
Sache mit dem Papa schwierig besonders
an der Schule der Doppelmord von
Babenhausen hat ja überall Schlagzeilen
gemacht Anja darf so tritt die Flucht
nach vorne an spricht mit den Lehrern
über ihre Situation
Anfeindungen und dumme Sprüche gibt es
trotzdem aber sie sagt das ist zum Glück
super abgefangen worden in dem darüber
gesprochen wurde die Kinder wussten dass
sie sich an ihre Lehrer wenden können
und ich dazu komme das hat ihnen
geholfen zu wissen dass sie einen Anker
hatten und dann ist er ja auch noch das
liebe Geld wir hatten das vorher schon
kurz erwähnt Andreas verdiente als
Einkäufer in einer Baufirma das Geld für
die ganze Familie nach dem Urteil steht
Anja mit der einkommensfrage jetzt
völlig alleine da sie hat nicht mal
meine Krankenversicherung sie spart wo
sie kann jobt Kauf secondhand ein und
immer wieder müssen ihre Eltern kommen
und auf die Kinder aufpassen alle zwei
Wochen fährt Anja darf so in die
Justizvollzugsanstalt nach Weiterstadt
in der Ehemann einsetzt für eine Stunde
Besuchszeit zwei Kinder dürfen mit sie
wechseln sich ab der jüngste kennt
seinen Vater nicht anders er war ja ein
Baby als Andreas da zu verhaftet wurde
er glaubt wie seine Familie Geschwister
Mutter Oma und Opa Freunde und Nachbarn
das sein Vater unschuldig ist
mehr als zehn Jahre lang geht das jetzt
so kann man da ein paar bleiben auch
darüber hat Lena mit Anja da so
gesprochen sie sagt dass Sie Andreas
immer noch liebt und dass sie auch noch
ein Ehepaar sein aber sei mir eine
Freundschaft geworden weil diese
Liebesbeziehung ein Liebespaar zu sein
können sie gar nicht mehr ausleben es
gibt im Gefängnis zwar ihr Räume aber
sie sagt sie findet es total absurd zu
wissen in diesem irrraum zu sein intim
zu werden und zu wissen dass draußen
auch 20 Beamte umherkreisen also das ist
eine Möglichkeit die die beiden nicht
nutzen wenn Anja alles zu viel wird dann
zieht sie ihre Laufschuhe an und rennt
acht Marathons ist jetzt schon gelaufen
ein neunter soll folgen sie lebt
übrigens bis heute in dem Doppelhaus
dass sie mit Andreas kaufte also direkt
neben dem Haus indem ihr Mann laut
Gericht seine Nachbarn erschossen
sie sagt ich wollte meine Kinder nicht
aus ihrem Zuhause reißen wir hätte ich
auch mit dem Namen da so eine neue
Wohnung finden sollen der hätten doch
alle gesagt das ist ja die Frau von dem
Mörder das ist noch viel schlimmer da
hätten wir dann schon unseren Namen
ändern müssen es gibt allerdings Tage da
hält sie es kaum aus zwischen all den
Erinnerungen an ihre eins zu heile Welt
manchmal werde ich fast verrückt es ist
ein Albtraum aus dem ich nicht mehr
aufwache es ist schlimmer als wäre er
gestorben ich kann keinen cut machen
die Sachen ihres Mannes hat Anja darsow
bis heute nicht weggeräumt seine
Unterwäsche zum Beispiel liegt noch im
Schrank
andreas hat im Gefängnis eine
Kochausbildung gemacht und arbeitet
jetzt auch dort als Koch wann er aus dem
Gefängnis kommt das weiß seine Familie
nicht die uns bildreporterin Lena Zander
berichtet kämpft die Familie zusammen
mit dem bekannten Anwalt Gerhard Strate
immer noch um ein
Wiederaufnahmeverfahren aktuell läuft
gerade noch einen Zivilprozess und zwar
geht es darum dass das Land Hessen dass
die Vormundschaft für Astrid hat Andreas
da so auf 70 000 € Schadenersatz
verklagt hat und zwar für die Versorgung
von Astrid Tee in erster Instanz hat das
Gericht auch gesagt Andreas da so muss
diese 70.000 € zahlen jetzt gibt es aber
eine zweite Instanz das ganze sollte ja
im Januar schon stattfinden und auf
diesen zweiten Termin wartet man jetzt
weil sich Andreas und Anja da so mit dem
Anwalt der hat Strate davon erhoffen
dass auch eine neue Beweis Aufnahme
stattfindet und da hoffen sie dann
weitere Beweise zu finden und einführen
zu können die auch Relevanz für einen
neuen Strafprozess bzw eine
Wiederaufnahme haben weil Andreas und
Anja da so gerade Anja da so draußen in
Freiheit immer noch dafür kämpft dass
ihr Mann aus dem Gefängnis kommt und
freigesprochen wird
Anja weiß genau wie sie sich die
Freilassung ihres Mannes wünscht er
kommt aus dem Tor hat einen Koffer in
der einen eine Pflanze in der anderen
hat eine romantische Vorstellung wie man
das im Film sieht ehrlich gesagt weiß
ich aber nicht was dann ist wie
kompatibel sind wir dann noch sind wir
dann wieder das Ehepaar das Liebespaar
wie wir eins waren
vielleicht möchte er auch erst einmal
alleine sein er soll nicht gleich wieder
in das nächste Gefängnis
über den Fall von Andreas darf so werden
wir euch auf dem laufenden halten
vielleicht gibt es schon bald
Nachrichten vom Zivilprozess falls dies
der Fall ist werdet ihr es hier im
Podcast erfahren und damit sind wir am
Ende des heutigen falls angelangt wir
danken euch fürs zuhören und freuen uns
wenn ihr auch beim nächsten Mal mit
dabei seid eure Toni und euer Mirko wir
haben diesen Fall mit Lena Zanders
Notizen aus dem Archiv von Axel Springer
erzählt auch ein Artikel der Frankfurter
Rundschau mit der Zeile mein Mann ist
unschuldig war sehr hilfreich Redaktion
Stefan Netze Band und Lena Zander
Schnitt und
Aufnahmestudios München